>> Nora Krug: Good afternoon.
I hope you're having a good
time at the Book Festival.
My name is Nora Krug, and I am
a book world editor and writer
at the Washington Post,
which is a charter sponsor
of the National Book Festival.
First I want to give a word
of thanks to the cochairman
of the festival,
David Rubenstein
and the other generous sponsors
who've made this event possible.
If you'd like to add
your financial support,
please note the information
in your program.
We'll have some time after this
presentation for your questions.
And I've been asked to
remind you that if you come
to the microphone, you'll
be included in the videotape
of this event, which may be
broadcast at a later date.
Our guest this afternoon
is Sylvia Acevedo.
She will be signing
at 4 PM over there.
But for now we get to
meet her in person.
Sylvia is a woman of
many hats and glasses.
She is an engineer,
a businesswoman,
and as you probably know her
best, as chief executive officer
of the Girl Scouts
of the United States.
[applause].
Among her many philanthropic
contributions has been providing
thousands of pairs of
glasses to children
who needed their
vision corrected.
But long before that,
Sylvia spent her childhood
in Las Cruces, New Mexico,
a place where she could
see a lot of stars.
And it was those stars that
inspired her to make a rocket
that would earn her a
brownie science badge.
The rocket didn't
actually get to the stars,
but her interest
in science grew.
And despite some challenges in
her life, she stuck with it.
She ended up at Stanford,
becoming one
of the first Hispanic
students, male or female,
to earn a graduate engineering
degree from the university.
She went on to fulfill
her childhood dream
and actually become
a rocket scientist
at the Jet Propulsion Labs.
She later worked as an engineer
at IBM before becoming
an executive
at several Fortune 100
companies -- Apple and Dell.
And in May of 2017,
this longtime Girl
Scout became the CEO,
and her life was transformed
by Girl Scouts and she has gone
on to transform Girl Scouts
itself by adding some science,
technology, and engineering
to the program.
And now she's added another
thing, which she is an author.
And this week her memoir,
"Path to the Stars," comes out.
It is a heartfelt story
about Sylvia's childhood
and shows how both the good and
the not so good that happened
to her led her to accomplish
all of the many things
that I have just described.
It's a beautiful and inspiring
story that I'm going to share
with my own nine-year-old
daughter,
and I hope that you
will share with yours.
And now to tell you more
about her life and her book
and Girl Scouts is
Sylvia Acevedo.
[ Applause ]
>> Sylvia Acevedo: Thank
you very much, Nora.
All right, Girl Scout
families, let's hear it.
[cheers]. That's wonderful.
We have so many go-getters,
innovators, risk-takers,
and leaders and the
families that love them.
So thank very much
for coming today.
So today I want to tell you
a little bit about my story,
my book, "Path to the Stars."
There we go.
So one of the things about
me is all my family was born
in Mexico.
My parents were born in Mexico.
My mom was born in Mexico.
My dad was born in
El Paso, Texas.
But my dad joined the military
and he was officer in the Army,
and he was stationed
in Ellsworth Air Force
Base in South Dakota.
And so what is up there?
That's right, Mount Rushmore.
I was born right
by Mount Rushmore.
So my parents were so excited
about being in South Dakota,
they bought all these different
things, like sugar bowls,
cookie bowls that had that image
of the presidents
on Mount Rushmore.
And so from when I
was a really girl,
the image of the presidents
and the United States was just
in my heart and in my head.
But then after that, my
parents decided to move back
to where they were from.
And so -- can you
play the mic --
I mean, play the video please?
So we moved to a
universe which seemed
so far away from South Dakota.
We moved all the
way to the desert
in Las Cruces, New Mexico.
Here we go.
We moved to this
town, Las Cruces.
And you can see,
it's the desert.
There's only one desert
dryer than that desert,
and that's the Sahara Desert.
So it's really dry.
But I loved it.
I loved my family.
I loved my friends in
that really small town.
And when you wonder how
small the town was, you know,
when you had to write
a letter to somebody,
you just put their name and the
street, you didn't even have
to put a zip code, the
town was that small.
And I loved that town because
you could see the stars.
And we had these
beautiful Oregon mountains,
and so you could just see
this really pretty scenery.
And everything about my family
was happiness and light.
But then one day my
brother, older brother,
and my younger sister
and I were playing,
and everything was fine.
But the next day my
brother went to school
and my sister didn't wake up.
And when I went to touch
her forehead, she was very,
very hot and nonresponsive.
And I went and got my mother.
And my mother went
and touched my sister
and realized she was so sick.
And we didn't have a
phone in the house.
My mother didn't drive a car.
And here she had a daughter
lifeless in her arms.
She went running
down the street,
knocking on doors,
crying to people.
[foreign language] Help me!
Help me, please!
Finally somebody found her and
got in a car and took my mom
and my sister to the hospital.
There was a meningitis
epidemic that had swept
through our home and
our neighborhood.
It's a serious disease,
some people die.
I was worried my sister would
die, but she didn't die.
But that insatiably hot fever
-- if any of you have kids --
your moms worry when
you have a fever,
they worry because if
your brain gets too hot,
your brain is forever changed.
And that's what happened
to my sister.
My sister, the one who was
the smartest of us all,
the one who could light
up a room with her energy.
She had become special
but in the Special
Olympics kind of way.
And so for my mother that
moment was really hard.
And she looked around and she
said, the only neighborhood --
the only neighborhood
where kids got sick
and there was a meningitis
epidemic was our neighborhood,
the neighborhood
with dirt streets.
And so for my mother, she
said, we're going to move.
And at that point my
mother said to my father,
I'm going to learn
to drive a car.
And then once she learned to
drive a car, she started driving
around and finding
another neighborhood,
a neighborhood with
paved streets.
And so we did move, she
found a new neighborhood
with paved streets.
And how many of you have
ever moved in the middle
of a school year to
a brand-new school?
Anybody have that experience?
There's a few.
Is that fun?
Not at all, not at all.
And so at that moment
-- why is it not fun?
Somebody said it.
Because everybody's
already made friends, right.
And so you come in the
middle of the school year
and everyone has
already made friends.
And so I hated that school.
And my teacher did
this very funny thing.
My new teacher, she put
all the smart kids by her,
and then the ones that
didn't do as well,
you got seated further away.
So when I entered
the new classroom,
they put my desk
the furthest away.
And the boy in front of
me turned around and said,
now you are the dumbest
one in class.
I hated that.
So I would run home
from school every day.
But one day, as I was
running home from school,
this girl kept following me.
And I would run faster and
she'd catch up with me,
and she was very persistent.
She was a go-getter.
She was a Brownie.
And she said, why don't you
come to Brownies with me?
And I said, no.
And she said, well,
we're in front
of your house, go
ask your mother.
So I went in to ask my mom.
Mom, can I go?
Have you ever asked
your mom a question
like you want the
answer to be no?
So I said, mom, you don't have
to say yes, but this girl,
she wants me to go
to this activity.
You don't have to say yes.
But my mother was excited,
because for the first time I
was showing some enthusiasm
around something
at the new school.
So she just wanted to
know where I would be,
and she said yes, go ahead.
So I went to that program
and I fell in love.
And there I was being a Brownie.
You can see, look
at how old I was.
I was missing a tooth, right.
I didn't care much
about fashion.
Look at my tie, right.
But what I discovered at
Girl Scouts and in Brownies,
that there were girls
like me, girls that liked
to do fun things, that
liked to do active things.
We did bike rides.
We did camping.
We did all sorts of fun things.
And it really opened
up my mind and my eyes.
And I liked it so much
that the next year I wanted
to join again.
But then when I saw that all
the fun things we had planned,
I said to my troop leader,
my family can't afford it.
You see, my family lived
paycheck to paycheck.
We lived in near poverty.
We didn't have savings.
And I said, how am I
going to afford this?
And my troop leader looked
at me and said, don't worry,
you know what we're going to do?
We're going to sell cookies.
And the cookie program
changed my life.
The reason is, is that when
you're raised in poverty
or near poverty or living
paycheck to paycheck,
you don't know how to
create opportunity.
And what the cookie
program taught me
and what my troop leader
taught me is, you set goals,
and then you breakdown that
goal into smaller parts.
And then once you have
the smaller parts,
you do those little things.
And pretty soon you've
achieved your goal.
And also, you set your budget.
And all those things
taught me so much.
The other thing that
she taught me is never
to give up and persistence.
So she taught me a life lesson
that I keep to this day.
Never walk away from a sale
until you've heard
no three times.
So the first time I
started selling cookies,
I went to everyone I knew -- I
went to people in my church --
they all bought, but I
still hadn't made my goal.
I needed to sell more cookies.
So I realized I was going
to have to talk to people
that I'd only seen
in the neighborhood
but never talked to.
So I went to the
neighbor and I asked her
if she would buy
cookies and she said, no.
And no one had ever
said no to me.
And I said, uh-oh.
But what had my troop
leader said?
You can't walk until away
until you hear no three times.
So then I said, is there
anybody else at that house
that would want to buy cookies?
And she said no.
And I stayed there,
and she looked
at me like, I've said no, go.
And I looked at her like,
I've only heard no two times.
So I look around her and
I look at her, and I said,
is there anybody's day
that you would make
if you bought a Girl
Scout cookie?
And she said -- okay,
she bought a box, okay?
So that taught me an important
lesson in persistence,
a lesson that I carried
my entire life.
The other thing is, I
learned about counting
up my cookies and
my cookie cash.
And that really taught me a
love of numbers and of science.
And one of the great
things about Girl Scouts is
that my troop leader saw
me looking at the stars.
And so when she saw me looking
at the stars, she
remembered that.
And later on she asked me, why
don't you earn a science badge?
And I decided to make a science
badge by making an Estes rocket.
And so to earn my science
badge, I made an Estes rocket.
And what I learned is you have
to get the chemicals right,
which are like the ingredients.
You have to get the
sequence right and you have
to get the heat right.
And when you do that, the rocket
finally went into the sky.
And that's a lot like cooking.
Cooking, you have to get
the ingredients right.
You have to get the order right.
You got to get the heat right.
And then you'll have success.
The other thing I learned in
Girl Scouts is I loved math,
and I didn't know that before.
But as I counted
up my cookie cash,
I counted up my cookie
dollars, I realized,
that was a lot of fun.
And then I also learned
to make things.
I wanted to make a duffel bag.
But there was no pattern
for making a duffel bag.
So my mother said to me, how are
you going to make a duffel bag,
especially a duffel bag
that has round ends?
And I said, don't worry,
mom, I did the math.
So I made the drawings, and then
I used this thing called pi,
and that tells you what
the circumference is.
And my mother said to me,
I'm glad you like math, meha.
So I was able to make
that great duffel bag.
And from those experiences
I learned so much
in Girl Scouts, but
so did my mother.
My mother, who only spoke
Spanish, through Girl Scouts,
my troop leaders befriended her.
They taught her English and
then they also taught her
that she could become a citizen.
So she had a green card
but my father had never
encouraged her to be a citizen.
And my troop leaders
So when I jumped up and
bridged from Brownie to Junior,
my mother had a bridging
ceremony herself,
and she became a US citizen.
My mom also ran a
Girl Scout troop
for my sister's developmentally
disabled class.
So my sister was able to
be a Girl Scout as well.
Now, one of the great things
I've learned later on is,
how do people escape when they
sometimes grow up in poverty
or their families don't
have a lot of money.
What I've learned is Girl Scouts
taught me there's four ways
to get out of poverty, and
Girl Scouts did all four
of those for me.
It helped me set a goal.
I had a caring adult, that troop
leader who looked out for me.
It taught me that I had an
amazing skill, which is math.
My math skills because of
Girl Scouts became so strong
that I kept taking
math and I was able
to be a rocket scientist.
And then also I learned I
didn't have to live that way,
that it was too painful to
stay, and I could get out.
So when I was in fourth grade --
I don't know how
many of you see this.
That's Stanford University.
But I saw a picture like that
when I was in fourth grade.
And I said to my teacher,
I want to go there.
And my teacher walked
up to me and she said,
that's Stanford University,
that's one of the best
places in the world.
And she said, and you're a
smart girl, you can go there.
So fourth grade, I decided I
was going to go to Stanford.
And as it turns out, not
only did I go to Stanford,
I was able to graduate
from Stanford University.
And I've had amazing
experiences.
I was actually -- I worked
as a rocket scientist.
There I am working
on the Davis gun
in the Tonopah Desert
at the test range.
Here I am loading up
a missile as well.
And then I worked at NASA
at the Jet Propulsion
Laboratories in Pasadena.
And I worked on two missions.
One was the Voyager II,
which went by Jupiter
and its moon Lo and Europa.
And so I got to do all
this amazing analysis.
It was the first time we
ever saw these great images
of Jupiter up close.
And I got to see them --
you know, was one of the
first people to see them,
and that was so exciting.
The other thing was I worked
on a mission called
Solar Polar Solar Probe.
It's just recently been
renamed Parker Solar Probe,
and it just launched
a few weeks ago.
And I worked on that
project decades ago.
And it was so great to
see it finally launch.
Because when you work on
something that's going
to the sun, you have to
think about so many things.
Like think about it.
What is the sun?
It's solar.
It's hot. So how do you have a
spacecraft that gets that close?
How about radiation?
How about solar wind?
What if it gets hit
by asteroids?
There are all these
things that you have
to think and factor into that.
And so took decades.
And that was so much
fun to be part
of the initial planning
phases of it.
So I've had a great
experience of being --
because from being a
little girl, I've been able
to be a rocket scientist
and I've been able
to fly through the sky.
I've been able to go para
jumping with the Golden Knights.
Imagine being three
miles high in the sky
and jumping from a plane.
It was an exciting experience.
And who would've thought
that that girl born
by Mount Rushmore would grow
up to have all these
amazing experiences?
And I knew I was able to have
these amazing experiences
because I was a Girl Scout.
And now I'm the CEO of
the Girl Scout of the USA.
[applause].
So I know we have lot of the
Girl Scouts in the audience.
And I wanted to make sure we
have some time for questions.
And I know we have
young Girl Scouts
and we have alumni Girl Scouts
and we have people who care
about Girl Scouts or just care
about the rising generation.
So you please go up to the mics.
Now, one of the questions people
ask me is: How about boys,
do they like the book?
And I have to say boys
like the book as well.
There's stories about
basketball.
There's stories about cars.
There's stories about rockets.
So they tend to like it as well.
I see we have a crowd,
so go ahead.
>> Why do you write?
>> Sylvia Acevedo:
Why do I write?
I love that question!
What happened was, I was talking
to kids like you, and there were
so many of them that wanted
to talk to me about my story,
that I realized the only
way I could reach so many
of them was if I wrote a book.
And so the book could be
in every school in America,
so they could be inspired.
It's a good question, thank you.
Over here?
>> What difficulties
did you have to overcome
in order to get into NASA?
>> Sylvia Acevedo:
Great question.
The challenges of getting in.
So first of all, your math has
to be really, really good, okay.
So you have to keep
taking hard math classes.
The other thing is when you
work in an all-male environment,
you have to be ready for that.
So how many of you saw
the movie Hidden Figures?
A lot of you.
Do you remember the
bathroom scene?
Okay, so what I like to say is,
they at least had a bathroom.
When I started working,
there were not even
any bathrooms for me.
So one of the challenges I
had to overcome was to figure
out where the closest
women's bathrooms were.
And they were far away, so I
had to bring a bike in to work
and drink just a
little bit of water.
And when I had to go to the
bathroom, I would hurry up
and go to those other places.
It took six weeks, but then
finally the other engineers
decided, okay, she's not
going to quit, she's got to,
you know -- we're going
to bring in a bathroom.
So they brought me my own
bathroom that said hers on it.
So you have to be persistent.
You have to be resilient,
you know.
And, for example, a lot of
the equipment didn't fit me,
like you'd have to
wear overalls.
Like if you saw that picture
of me working on the Davis gun,
you might not have noticed
but I had to put duct tape,
because it didn't fit me.
It wasn't made for
somebody my size.
But I never gave up.
I was persistent.
Okay, another question.
>> Okay, so I'm one of
the older Girl Scouts.
>> Sylvia Acevedo: Hi there.
>> Hi. My name is Sylvia too.
>> Sylvia Acevedo:
Oh, great name.
>> So we adults know that
young people hear what we say,
but they learn more
from what we do.
So what did you learn --
what one thing did you learn
from the people you
saw and heard
from that shaped you today?
>> Sylvia Acevedo: So, you know,
I really learned persistence.
I think I was talking
about that story
where my troop leader wouldn't
let us walk away from a sale
until we heard no three times.
And I saw her do that as well.
So it's so important to
not just say be persistent
but model it as well.
Very good question.
Over here.
>> What's your favorite
type of Girl Scout cookie?
>> Sylvia Acevedo: My
favorite type of --
that's a really good question!
So I will tell you, when
my mother was a cookie --
she ran the cookie campaign.
And one year we had to be the
cookie cupboard at our house.
And we didn't have a garage,
so we moved our furniture
to the backyard, and our
entire house was stacked
floor-to-ceiling
with cookie boxes.
And to walk down our hall,
you had to walk sideways.
But there was one cookie
that I wanted to be
in my bedroom stacked
floor-to-ceiling,
and that would be -- thin mints!
It's thin mints!
Good question.
Okay.
>> Hi.
>> Sylvia Acevedo: Hi.
>> Alumni Girl Scout
and troop leader.
>> Sylvia Acevedo:
Yes, thank you.
>> What is one piece of
advice that you would give
to our current Girl Scouts
so that they can
succeed in their life?
>> Sylvia Acevedo: So first
thing that you can do to succeed
in your life is be a Girl Scout.
I mean, half of all of our
female elected officials
in America were Girl Scouts.
Three-fourths of our
senators, Girl Scouts.
Almost every female
governor, a Girl Scout.
[cheering].
And almost every
astronaut in space,
female astronauts, a Girl Scout.
When I go to Silicon Valley,
almost all the female
leaders, Girl Scouts.
So the one thing I would say
that you have an amazing
advantage in Girl Scout
that you don't have in any other
youth organization is getting
your gold award.
If you get your gold
award, that's like helping
to write your college essay.
And there's all these
scholarships available.
This man came to my office and
he wanted to give me a hug.
And I said, fine, but why?
And then he said, because my
daughter's gold award project
was so good, it was
her college essay,
and she got a four-year
scholarship at one
of the top universities
in America all paid
for because of her gold award.
So the gold award gets
your kid into college,
top colleges, with scholarships.
So I would really
encourage them to do that.
Okay, next one.
>> What was the name of the girl
that inspired you
to be a Girl Scout?
>> Sylvia Acevedo:
Oh, what was the name
of the girl that invited me?
Actually, I know her name.
Her name is Sylvia Black.
So we've got a lot
of Sylvias going on.
But I remember her.
Thank you.
>> What changed your mind
about going to Brownies?
>> Sylvia Acevedo:
Great question,
I write about that in the book.
Because once I was there --
remember, my sister had been
sick, my family had gone
through a big trauma
and tragedy.
And when we were doing a craft
project, making sit upons --
so we were cutting
fabric and newspapers
and weaving them together
so we'd have something
to sit upon -- how many
of you know sit upons?
Okay, great, you know sit upons.
Well, we were sitting in the
circle and I handed the scissors
to the girl pointy edge first.
And our troop leader stopped
and she asked the Brownies
to demonstrate the safe
way to pass scissors,
which is always not
the pointy edge, right.
And so they did that
and they also told me,
never run with scissors.
Okay, so I never knew
there was any rules
about passing scissors, much
less one and two rules, right.
So at that moment I realized,
if Girl Scouts cared enough
about me about how
I pass scissors,
imagine how much more
they would care about me.
And it turns out they
cared about me so much,
and it changed my life.
So that was the moment I said,
I'm going to be in Girl Scouts.
>> Okay, thank you.
>> Sylvia Acevedo: Thank you.
>> I forget.
>> Sylvia Acevedo: It's okay.
I'm glad you're a Girl Scout.
Yes?
>> Hello.
>> Sylvia Acevedo: Hi.
>> What changed your
life about doing math?
>> Sylvia Acevedo: What changed
my life about doing math?
That I really enjoyed counting.
But when was in Girl Scouts,
I didn't realize
math had a purpose.
And so when I was
counting my cookie cash
and counting the
number of boxes I sold,
I realized that math could
help me reach my goals.
And that made math fun for me.
So after that, I
realized math was fun.
And so math became a way that I
learned I could make my goals.
So that, when I was in
Girl Scouts around fourth
or fifth grade, that helped me.
>> Thank you.
>> Sylvia Acevedo: I know
her, her name is Amanda.
And Amanda wants to be an
astronaut, right, Amanda?
>> Yes.
>> Sylvia Acevedo: Yay!
>> So did you see
Voyager II launch?
>> Sylvia Acevedo:
Okay, no, I didn't get
to watch Voyager II launch.
It was already in orbit when
I started working at JPL.
But thank you, good
question, Amanda.
>> How did you build the rocket?
>> Sylvia Acevedo:
Okay, good question.
How did I build the
rocket, the Estes Rocket?
It came in a kit, and I actually
had to buy several kits,
because I did it wrong the
first two or three times.
And my parents made me use my
allowance, so it took me a while
to actually earn that badge.
Because you to be careful.
And I learned that you had to
read the directions just right,
and you had to get
the heat just right,
and then you put
the kit together.
And when I did that, I finally
was able to get it to launch.
But very good question.
>> Thank you.
>> Sylvia Acevedo: Thank you.
>> Which kind of
cookies do you like?
>> Sylvia Acevedo: She asked
what kind of cookies do I like.
I like all cookies, I
like all the cookies.
I do have a little bit
of a favorite preference
for thin mints.
But I'll eat a Girl
Scout cookie anytime.
Good question.
>> Why did you want to
be a rocket scientist?
>> Sylvia Acevedo: Why did I
want to be a rocket scientist?
You know, when I was making
my rocket for Girl Scouts,
you know, it took
me several times.
And the thing that
amazed me was,
how come it doesn't just launch?
How come it can't just get
up off the desert sand?
And so I learned about
this thing called gravity.
And so to me I became
fascinated with,
how do you break gravity's grip?
And so the rest of my life,
I was always thinking,
how do I break gravity's grip?
And then I thought rocket
scientists, that's what they do.
So that's why I went to work at
NASA at JPL, working on that.
I didn't want to
be an astronaut.
All right, we have time for
a couple more questions.
>> When did you start
being an author?
And what was the first
badge that you got?
>> Sylvia Acevedo:
Okay, great questions.
I started being an author four
years ago, when I was talking
to kids and they wanted to get
my book and I knew I needed
to reach more of them.
And I think my first
badge was a cycling badge.
Great question.
Okay, coming up to end.
>> Since you liked
the stars so much,
why weren't you an astronaut?
>> Sylvia Acevedo: You
know, I was more interested
in how do you get a rocket to
leave earth and breaking gravity
than actually being
up in the space.
That was a different
interest of mine.
I was never interested in being
a rocket -- I mean an astronaut.
It's just a different interest.
And I'm glad I did what I did.
I have friends that
are astronauts,
and that's fantastic,
but I'm glad
that I lived the
life that I did.
All right.
>> Last one.
>> Sylvia Acevedo:
Last one, okay.
Go ahead. All right, so
we're going to wrap it up.
So what I want to thank you.
The book is in English
and Spanish.
In Spanish it's "Camino a las
Estrellas, Path to the Stars."
Make sure you have
it in your libraries.
Make sure that you get it.
I hope that it inspires to
have your own dreams come true
and your own path to the stars.
Thank you very much.
[cheering].
And because we're so many girls,
why don't we do Make
New Friends?
How's that?
All right, ready?
1, 2, 3.
>> [Group Singing -
Make New Friends]:
Make new friends,
but keep the old.
One is silver, the
other is gold.
A circle is round,
it has no end.
That's how long, I
will be your friend.
>> Sylvia Acevedo: All right,
thank you very much, everybody!
See you at the book signing.